quand on parle de succès en entreprise
on pense généralement de croissance mais
pour et il existait une autre définition
du succès on est allé à la rencontre de
deux hommes bien différents mais qui ont
un point en commun on s'arrache leur
création d'un côté un fromage mythique
de l'autre une bière légendaire mais
malgré le succès et la renommée les deux
ont choisi de rester petit
[Musique]
voici jacques maillot et dans lotbinière
on l'appelle jack le chevrier à côté de
ses voisins qui font presque tous de
l'agriculture intensive jacques détonne
avec sa régie biologique ccal pondeuses
et ses chèvres il est un marginal
with avait
[Musique]
tenu les bb bb-
j'adore trail avec l'achat matière pour
moi je tenais mal un peu mystique
j'aime cet animal très intelligent
facile d'approché dos et communique
beaucoup avec l'humain bien botté bien
votre bouée ou et oui jacques adoue
chèvre il en a déjà eu plus mais il a
choisi de réduire son troupeau pour
simplifier le travail les avenues
conclut l'entreprise veut développer au
lieu de toujours fox et pour le montrer
la productivité passédat croire une
rentabilité une façon la croix de la
rentabilité c'est de réduire les
dépenses
[Musique]
moi je tenais d'entreprise je tenais à
partir d'une entreprise un peu non le
gros saut modeste on n'a pas besoin
nécessairement de croître l'entreprise
énormément pour aller chercher plus
hauts revenus c'est quelque chose qui
que tu apprends un moment donné
bienvenue à val d'espoir en gaspésie à
la brasserie ovale chez benoît couillard
chaque été des milliers de touristes
font la file ici pour mettre la main sur
quelques bouteilles vendues un nombre
limité
la grande majorité de la bea produits
d'ici ne sortira jamais de la région on
est vraiment désolé
pour moi c'est juste naturel que les
détaillants ou les gens près de la
brosserie ont accès aux produits je
trouve ça dommage que j'en envoie un peu
partout mais que les gens ici du coin
repas avoir accès fait que je suis c'est
juste naturel j'habite à cap d'espoir
l'aja côté mais l'épicerie à cap
d'espoir c'est important pour moi qui ai
qu'ils soient bien servis belle passe à
la suivante le voile le village suivant
moi je me considère plus comme un
artiste en brossacais comme pour voir ce
à l'industriel de bière je veux
démontrer que le modèle d'affaires est
possible et viable est intéressant sans
mettre trop de pression sur sur les
humains qui composent labrosse bip son
environnement
[Musique]
la brasserie d'entourer de terres
agricoles benoît et son équipe ils font
pousser des céréales et des petits
fruits des plantes pollinisées par leurs
abeilles ici c'est l'environnement qui
impose son rythme aux brasseurs je suis
mis un peu plus l'inspiration que je que
je lai que je vois de l'avant souvent
c'est toujours été comme ça il y avait
des plans de darwinia qui était dans un
système agroforestier ici je connaissais
même pas prêt ce fruit la goethe arrivé
à celles à venir dont j'ai assez de fans
d'eric lavagne est ici à côté mais
amplement son petit manteau pour pour
agrémenter pompe pour nourrir ma
créativité klein produits qu'on consomme
en oblique ce
mail à la bière on dirait que c'est
quasiment un produit de synthèse faite
en usine quel par la ccl nous on a cédé
2 mètres ammann affole battre de montrer
que la bia s'impose une agriculture
j'aime pas ça se produit d'ailleurs
simplement s'est pas produit
une bière on parle de biens d'un fromage
pas un produit starpass impuissant
[Musique]
bonjour je serais bien content de soi
chez
moi que je me suis établi ici je savais
qu'il fallait y mettre les bouchées de
mon deuxième métier me plaît énormément
c'est l'accomplissement de travail quand
une transformation tu vois un produit
fini le plaisir de fait soit marché que
tout au cours de la saison on voit que
la qualité et le fromage évolué avec
toutes les matières premières qui quel
animal peut prendre quelqu'un qui fonda
joue une fromagerie anneaux pour une vie
expérimentés
oui oui que ce choeur oui oui oui oui
bonjour beauté bonjour beauté le succès
comme d'un fromage n'est pas attribuée
tout à la fromagerie le succès d'un
fromage repose à 75% de ce qui se passe
l élevage une chèvre santé une chèvre
qui est brute du foin de qualité tous
que la chèvre mange tout ce que la chevy
se reflète dans laquelle sont en laine
ce qui se reflète dans lequel tu sois
manche
on
[Musique]
comment
pouvoir être mon propre patron c'était
vraiment précieux pour moi puis c'est un
métier
écoutez un métier passionnant qui
englobe plein d'aspects je n'avais
jamais je serais jamais arrivé au bout
des connaissances dans ce domaine le
fait que toujours quelques choses à
peaufiner améliore doit arriver le degré
supérieur
d'élégance et de
file d'attenté aussi
moche quelqu'un de muscu et
perfectionner je suis très heureux
aujourd'hui d'avoir ma façon de rassurer
les voisins m'ont regardé ali pendant
plusieurs années à savoir quand est-ce
qu'ils vont durer premier temps vous
verrez sur d'affaires les gens sont
ouverts au domaine biologique sont
conscients de l'environnement sont
conscients de
l'écoresponsabilité aussi d'avoir le
moins de gaspillage d'encourager une
posture qui est plus local moi je
voulais fait partie est de stores
marcello
à
[Musique]
pense tout la nature nous donne ce qu'on
a besoin fernand animales que végétales
[Musique]
présentement je suis vraiment dans un
modèle de
plancher sur la décroissance ça c'est
quand même de faire un petit point de
presque 2 annoncé en grande pompe mon
plan de croissance sur quelques années
pour raser probablement réduire je pense
améliorer la qualité de vie puis la
qualité de notre environnement qui nous
entourent mais il va vont moins
production mais voilà - d'autres
semblent s être artisanale s'est
automatiquement manqué d'ambition
entrepreneuriat
interdisant la aujourd'hui c'est une
belle façon d'exprimer ses idées ce
transfert enfin que oui c'est totalement
possible d'avoir une petite entreprise
plus à l'étape modèle pour qu'une
famille peut sans avis tout simplement
anglais xxème siècle ap ben de la fadeur
je trouve sur notre perception de ce qui
se trouve sur les étalages sur des
tablettes c'est incroyable quand on
garde son nom c'est nora médecins plus
haut les pendules à l'heure et tant
mieux si la population qui sont fonction
de ces veillées pour voir soupçons
[Musique]
acheter ce qu'on fait
en côtoyant jacques et benoît on réalise
le choix de rester petit c'est aussi un
refus du rythme imposé par notre société
la croissance de leur entreprise a été
remplacée par une quête du bonheur et de
l' équilibre
[Musique]